David Cross is coming up see here I saw
in the bathroom so when everyone yeah I
just saw Mary comes it was this killer
Mike yeah that's right that's right I'll
have to play later yeah I love to play
later man that was a pendulum by Stephen
car factory was the band yes it was but
Stephen colony why we were on the area
live live it's a pal what's going on man
how you doing buddy good what are you
doing just hanging out okay yeah thank
you just in New York doing doing my
stuff and I always like when I see
community when I'm walking in for
interview I always like when this comics
in there for some reason I just feel
more comfortable if I'm like just me and
the [ __ ] crew it's like oh yeah I
always like when there's another act
there at least it just mean the crew is
their energy is shitty you can't be
funny with just one or two people we're
just kind of looking eyes like yeah but
there's I mean there is a diminishing
returns when you get more and more and
more comics in there they can't be here
you can't everybody's talking over
themselves again here every it's all
competitive you can get like that yeah
so I'm just I would suggest getting rid
of Doug for the next hour how's things
been man I mean I you've had a kind of
interested in a couple months
yeah it's been it's you know I'm on the
up side you know but it's some personal
stuff and you know and professional
stuff and social media stuff and it all
just happened at once but yeah it's
getting better
did you think it went any point I'm
happy you guys are on Netflix did you
was there any point where you guys were
worried like oh they might just pull the
plug in panic or were you did you kind
of know that they wouldn't um I I
wouldn't say that I was a hundred
percent solid that they wouldn't but I
mean I'm friendly with Ted and we talked
a couple of times and I know some of the
other folks are and I never got the
sense that they would do that they
canceled a bunch of the publicity stuff
that was coming
directly after that that was all
cancelled and you know I mean that's
it's that's the way things are now and I
don't think they'll ever go back to
being kind of what they were and and
part of what everybody's learning is
when something like that happens and you
have no control over you know 100
million people yelling you just you you
recede a little bit let it calm down
it'll never completely go away but you
let it calm down because there will be
something else to replace that outrage
whether it's sincere or Foe it's I mean
Roseanne that Roseanne thing happened I
think 48 hours 72 hours later something
like that and then you know barely
anybody was you know and especially I
guess in a relative sense it was it was
not as you know not perceived not as
horrific Lee as what you know Roseanne
did and and then there's something else
two days after that this isn't weird to
like when you whenever you're in a
problem on Twitter which is like and
we've all said [ __ ] where people get
pissed off and this is overwhelming
avalanche and and even though you're a
stand-up and you've been screamed that
there are moments we're like holy [ __ ]
like it can it get you at moments no
matter how jaded to it you are there are
moments we like oh my god this is well
yeah first of all it's it's hatred and
sometimes it's violent and and then
there's also the frustration of this
feeling of like Jesus did is what I did
really that terrible and warrants this
kind of outrage and then there's that's
coupled with a an overall depressive
feeling about who we are what we are
what we become and it's depressing you
know it in it and it's like there's no
conversation anymore it's just [ __ ] you
yeah what how did that it what's the
dynamic of that interview obviously you
know what we've been talking about is
the group cast interview that you guys
all did promoting the time Arrested
Development oh I thought you were
talking about the picture of us put in
the
see cookies in the oven no no no in
hindsight that had to be but like I read
you know as you read the transcripts and
stuff I'm like it read almost like it
devolved pretty quickly into this odd
group therapy session thing yes it was
uh and and let me say I I went back and
I definitely have a different feeling
about it now having read it and
remembering it then I did in the moment
in the moment it didn't seem so
egregious and I definitely get the you
know the criticism I truly do and I and
I said I think you know why I said this
early on and I now I'm now gonna rescind
it but initially I was like I think we
got what we deserved and then but then
you know I know I think that's there was
too much it's yeah they continue to get
much much worse we don't still deserve
this don't you hate when they think they
know the motives that's the hardest part
when people say you do this for this
yeah yeah no that's not why I did that
that started way before that kind of
thinking I don't know I don't know what
to call it but swear you may you know
you have this somebody and it would be
in that's just since the advent of kind
of Internet chat room stuff where a
person would posit a theory on anything
whatever I mean it could be you know
that's a good example or even just
something that you know you participated
in or a show you wrote and why did they
do this thing or whatever the thing is
and then somebody on the thread posits
this theory and that just becomes fact
you're like no that's not we're a joke
I've been miss had jokes misinterpreted
and then people especially when you see
a joke in print which you know how awful
that yes and and then somebody will put
that in and it's kind of paraphrase it's
not even you know you're taking
something that you've crafted that has
there's a reason why you worded it that
way you
there's cadence there's finality there's
you know all that kind of stuff that
goes into a joke and telling
and then it's put on somebody writes it
out I push culture on the wrong part of
it and then somebody posits this theory
and then that's just the rest of the
thread is this assumption that is
completely false and that people are
getting pissed off at that thing and I
think you can extrapolate that into
where we are currently especially with
social media and stuff and and you know
that that's just one of the several ways
and I don't want it I'm not you know
bitching or you know playing the victim
that's just where we are now and I have
learned some lessons from this thing and
and as I said I you know if you look
back at it you can't see like oh wow we
really are jumping over talking over
Jessica and I know why we did it I know
why we said the things we said but one
of the lessons I've learned is nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your context nobody
they don't you know if there's a crying
woman in the room or whoever there's
somebody crying nobody cares about your
well butts or any context to the
situation which is that's how it is now
you can't intellectualize your way out
of certain things yeah they hear what
they want to hear right so that's what
are you feeling at that moment like when
that happened you guys just doing an
interview and then you see this thing
happening and somebody's upset and it's
getting like tensions okay but this is
like well this is uncomfortable like I
just as a person on the show what what
are you thinking like how are you
feeling in that moment well it was you
know I'm being very careful now because
I don't want to go through this [ __ ]
again I just got back on Twitter like
yesterday right we're taking a
sabbatical
but the
I don't know I I mean there's stuff I'm
happy to tell you off the air but then
we could have a discussion it would know
this now becomes a statement to the
press on the matter I wasn't asking like
what you said I can I know in those
moments we feel a certain way like oh no
this is hard sometimes let me I will say
this we we this wasn't a group of
strangers we have known each other and
work together for 15 years we know each
other's behavior behavior patterns we
it's not this wasn't a room full of
strangers right and and and I think that
there is I know I am privy to more
information than anybody else's except
for the people in that room again I
don't think what we did was right and I
wouldn't hopefully I won't do that again
I will stop and let the thing play out
and it was very quickly as you were
pointing out it was kind of like oh wow
we're in this psychotherapy session
which we should have been but in a
conversation probably shouldn't have
been done with no interviewer in the
room no absolutely and and and I you
know we I wrote an email to Jessica I
know everybody else did and and you know
we've all been talking again we're
friends we don't wish anything but the
best for everybody there's no enemies
there and you know and and occasionally
in that kind of family you have a you
have this outburst and also what Jeffrey
did wasn't cool
I mean having an outburst is okay but
the way what it was which nobody was
there for that wasn't cool like it's a
it's like okay enough he said your piece
right but it wasn't it went beyond that
sure and but I know why I know where it
came from I know it wasn't and I'm
giving you context nobody does matter
and to me though there's to us but sure
right people don't carry sufficient
rusev
tune of a reaction that's like if you
guys didn't react perfectly because it
was a moment that you didn't plan for
right what I took out of that whole
thing was regardless of what happened
between them regardless what you said
it's how people crucify you
if you don't react in a live moment a
hundred percent how in hindsight they
think you should have reacted like you
know leasing a lot of times these aren't
things you've had two days to think
about and go this is gonna happen
here's your reaction sometimes you just
try to talk your way through it or
trying to make it okay or and all the
sudden it doesn't work out the way you
wanted it to and people act like your
motives were to be shitty and that's
what I found was just so irritating
about it
well I to be fair I don't think a lot of
the issues people had were that we were
trying to be shitty I think it what the
the gist of what I saw was [ __ ] these
men these are you know look at this is a
very male thing and and because of our
what we said and how we did talk over
her it just became representative of
this is what's wrong with men and I
think it was less a little less of like
Batemans an [ __ ] you know some of
that stuff or for Tony and myself and
and Jason but it was mostly this is this
is men this is what we have to deal with
and and that and you know it was of
course we all got personal [ __ ] but and
it was also a bummer because you know we
we were happily you know up until that
moment sure that was not the that was
probably day three or four of doing
stuff we did stuff in LA we did stuff
here and and you know we were happily
promoting this thing that we liked
should we all and this was also
referencing something that happened I
mean half a year ago and and we moved on
quickly you know that happened on this
run though it wasn't on prior shoes it
was it was when we were shooting this
the series and
we're about halfway through the shoot I
think roughly and and it wasn't an easy
shoot and it certainly wasn't easy for
Jessica who I have nothing but respect
for and she like a lot of us you know
we're getting new pages you get I mean
it was it was not cool as an for an
actor it was a difficult time because
for myriad reasons I won't go into but
you know we'd get a script they weren't
done you'd get something at night it'd
be [ __ ] you know pages and pages of
stuff and then it would change later on
that night and then you get in the
morning and it'd be you know you'd have
two and a half new pages of flung stuff
and that's hard for anybody
yeah it's also harder when you're older
you know and it's not it it's one of the
things that added to the tension and
people weren't able to do the scenes
correctly that and that was a big big
part of it and and everybody has trouble
with it and especially you know if
you're older it's it's even more
difficult I remember you know anyway but
getting all those new pages and then if
you're screwing it up and then so it's
Maddie for screwing right before I see
how much you know it's that's hard to do
well it in fairness it wasn't about her
screwing it up but it was it was it's
just tough yes tough for anybody and and
it was a chaotic set and but you know
we're again I can't stress this enough
and it because it's important we all
love each other yeah and we've known
each other we want to work together
again we I wish these things had been
dealt with prior to the the interview
where it all started coming out I take
blame for that for not because I'm I'm
usually fairly good at going okay guys
we need a timeout and you know I mean
I'm just an actor in this show but I've
certainly directed plenty of things and
produce things and you know you you you
should be and I was I was cognizant of
that we need a break right now this we
need to discuss this you know take take
let's take 30 minutes and let's all go
talk about this as friends and
co-workers and let's you know but I
never did that nobody did that and and I
take blame for that I should have
because I've recognized it and I didn't
do anything
it really is funny watching people not
in reference to this specifically but
trying to grab headlines as I was
looking up last night Perez Hilton had
this headline that was David Cross
awkwardly walks off of Stephen Colbert
show that and like I watched it and I'm
like I can't believe this is a story
Stephen Colbert made David Cross cry and
people you know that wasn't planned we
just that was just night I'd known
Stephen for a long time and he's really
one of the best improvisers he doesn't
get enough credit for his skill at that
and and I just did that knowing it would
be silly and we had no idea where it was
gonna go or what was gonna happen it was
very clearly a bit though right like we
didn't plan it out no disgusted oh it's
absolutely watching like you guys are
both having a good time we should get
some clickbait going on the show is over
soon so we should say David Cross walks
out of interview we want to say that it
was the end of the show right then we'll
get some put that is what they do though
what are you talking about
oh come on tore up bless you Jim
official David Cross that calm and he's
gonna be here on this Friday all right
what was the name of the website where
do you do official David Cross com
yeah that's right there's one you say
one more time oh well you know well
Twitter's David Cross with 3 s's yeah
but if you want to go visual David Cross
com
yeah that's where you go to get tickets
coming to what city
huh Friday the Knitting Factory here in
our New York you see me in Brooklyn
Saturday
Columbus Theatre in Providence and then
Sunday's the Wilbur the Great Wilbur
theater in Boston it's one of my
favorite places to work I shot a special
there yeah yeah I've shot two there wait
where were you would shoot the Wilbur
Wilbur yeah I went to the Somerville
theatre which I love oh I've been that's
again done shows there long I did Barry
Crimmins got
whole night together with for howard
zinn and we did this huge show is really
great are you from Boston or no no I
lived there for nine years
okay weirdly where I cut my teeth calm
guys also I'm sorry I threw David dates
for David through August official David
crossed calm he's got gigs in Oregon
Seattle Philly i aspirated part it's
good yeah there's [ __ ] there's a bunch
yeah how did tobias end up making his
cameo in the Avengers film there's a
scene like when you go into like the
collector or whoever when they're in all
like these glass containers and vials
and bottles you just see David's
character from Arrested Development just
in there well Joe and Anthony Russo the
Russo brothers who directed that movie
also directed I forgot they came for a
second Arrested Development and they you
know they really created the look and
the template for that and they were
there for the for the first year
directing and and they also directed the
pilot for the increasingly poor
decisions of Todd Margaret which I did
over in London and so I know them we've
known them for a while and I think they
put other I want to say they've done
other arrested there's other references
and I believe oh the stair cars and
somewhere I know I'm not gonna pretend
that I don't know what you're talking
about because I've done enough of the
answer that question enough but I
haven't seen the movie haven't even look
up the scene or the photo front of you
know I don't I haven't seen any of those
movies right if there's a cape I'm
usually far far away
was like if you if you watch the first
10 then you'll be able to jump on this
one
easy there won't be an issue burned by
those say every you know every year
there's a new thing where people like no
no I know you don't like this no but
this one is really great it's different
and then he going you're like let's like
I remember guardians of the galaxy I was
really psyched to see that and I bought
into the hype like didn't know this
turns it on its ear you know it's a and
you know Chris Pratt's really great I
like this stuff
they were doing that wasn't the
superhero stuff but then it was you know
half of the movie is still a guy in
purple paint
you know how colic and you know the
energy balls of Gravitron or whatever
going
we must for the sake of our rhythm you
know all that bullsh I'm happy you said
that cuz I've never seen that movie and
these guys are always trying to tell me
how great it is I'm like no it's a pile
of [ __ ] I don't want to say it yeah
wouldn't say it's a pile of [ __ ] but
it's not going you're not gonna walk out
of there it's not like Deadpool right
were you like oh that was [ __ ] funny
that was just nothing but funny [ __ ] the
way I haven't seen that either it's good
it's fun it's good but it still it is
still at its core a superhero movie so
you can kind of like a fight with it all
the time constantly if I ask you though
to guess what is the plot what happens
in the middle and how does it end you
could probably you could probably make a
pretty safe bet about it yeah without
Margot Kidder I don't want to see
yourself a Lois yes [ __ ] that
drinking voice yeah